росіянам а гаїті ви 100 в цю україну
негативному світили історію з неба то
знак на ньому адвоката російського скронь
а служба вся Олександра Олександрова
Юрія Грабовського просто заявила по наділу
головні весь кого прокурор України
анатолій матіос
за його словами а потім вона підозрюваного
в організації знака не адвокатом окей
спеціально за хорошими кішки тут його
спеціальну операцію по створі
ілюзії щодо відомості перебування і при
хова не я одна захист nickel
російських віско служба вчив роботу
замішані україни чи це скандал і тиснява
лави краду не грабовського року дав і
також скорботи адвокатської оксани
соколівської еко захищаючи in java
російського скронь і служба вся олена
ерофєєва
за 3 мани в Україні дзвонова
звіт про тероризм
на apb1 а українські ризикові підрозділи
та зручності
захисниця 1 зима вірних російських
диверсантів соколівсько
поважається причинну піску і до його навіч
і вояка збоку істоти і збоку право
охоронців
вивчаючи політика і тому на палітрі колір ми
знаємо засовуються абсолютно різанини за
собор соколівсько знай дави руб
залишалося одне заїва матіаса
і ви слова лаз кребса сюди метод в
роботи головної ризикової прокуратури
адвокат до будете за свою bespeco і
адже вимагаючи суду треба ти їх втрату
доступна доступна особлива особа
може не батіг і всім може ніби я
суд у пана справах забав я за вас був
запас плаче і за хоч для соколівської
у свою чергу матиас винуватів пам'ятники
в адвокатів за крима та соколівської в
тому що вони стрибка джаз листя
встановлено не залишиться місця перебування
адвоката грабовського